meeting the diplomacy drum but almost
reduced the g6 instead of the g7 EU
foreign policy chief federica mogherini
stood in for German Foreign Minister
frank-walter Steinmeier he arrived eight
hours late after his plane broke down
punched out don't finger down and watch
the Japanese chose this venue with care
Hiroshima symbolizes like no other place
the responsibility all countries have
for a world without war for a more
peaceful planet lately he reveled
however Hiroshima is not only a memento
of the horrors nuclear warfare can
inflict another cause lies behind me
behind the western horizon north korea
it tested a nuclear weapon just two
months ago the territorial dispute
between China and its neighbors over the
South China Sea will also be on the
summit agenda Japan is proud of its
status as the only Asian country among
the seven most advanced economies in the
world a planned joint declaration on
security of the maritime trade routes in
the region is a clear sign of support
for Japan in the face of its powerful
neighbors Russia and China